let's be 100 real no one expected this
to be the headline 24 hours later
oscar's rocked by what went down between
will smith and chris rock welcome to
entertainment tonight shocking confusing
yeah this moment that overshadowed a
night of so many oscar first and we've
got what you didn't see from will's live
tv smackdown
[Music]
denzel said to me a few minutes ago he
said at your highest moment be careful
that's when the devil comes for you
it was like at first you thought oh my
god it's a skit oh my god just wait a
minute there's no punch line wait whoa
it's a punch not a punch line
keep my wife's name
it was like shocking frankly it was
shocking well hitting somebody is a
crime right it is the crime yeah assault
it was a great night tonight
i seen a man stand up for his wife which
we don't see that much anymore
that made me have hope
chris rock who has declined to press
charges was presenting the best
documentary award when he joked about
jada's appearance jada i love you g.i
jane 2 can't wait to see it all right
we'll laugh but jada rolled her eyes and
looked annoyed then oh richard
[Laughter]
oh wow
[Applause]
wow will smith
at this point the audio feed is cut to
u.s audiences but uncensored clips
broadcast overseas show exactly what
happened next
will smith just smack
me
wow dude
yeah it was a g.i james keep my wife's
name out
i'm going to okay
here's what else viewers didn't see when
the show went to commercial will was
spotted talking intently to tyler perry
and denzel washington as denzel walks
will back to a seat bradley cooper
starts talking to will and they end
their moment with a hug
so what set will off his defenders point
to this
this is going to be a little bit more
difficult for me to hide last year jada
posted this video about a new patch of
baldness caused by alopecia and back in
2016 chris made another jaded joke when
he was host it involved the controversy
over no black acting nominees jason's
going to boycott the ocean jada boycott
in the oscars is like me boycotting
rihanna's panties
i wasn't invited
back to last night 35 minutes after will
slap
he was in tears accepting his best actor
oscar for king richard i want to
apologize to the academy i want to
apologize to my all my fellow
nominees love will make you do crazy
things
how did you feel about will's speech i
would like to more of a straight apology
to chris
we're told chris was still in shock over
the incident last night but he was
smiling and seemed to be having a good
time at gaio series after party but
could will be forced to give back his
oscar today the academy said it condemns
will's actions and has started a formal
review around the incident this morning
whoopi goldberg who's an academy
governor had wills back we're not going
to take that oscar from him
will sure didn't look worried at the
after party he was ready to celebrate
will and jada arrived here to the vanity
fair party just after midnight he walked
in carrying his oscar alongside jada and
their kids everyone was smiling and a
crowd actually gathered as the crew
stopped to pose for photos
earlier co-host amy schumer used the
chaos to get one of the night's biggest
laughs i've been getting out of that
spiderman costume did i miss anything
amy later posted we are all going to be
processing tonight for a while alongside
picks of her date hubby chris fisher who
she kissed on the carpet does gene get
to stay up and watch mama tonight i
don't know i i hope he chooses me
come on we need the ratings gene what a
beautiful couple and we're honoring a
lot of couples penelope and javier
bardem and maggie and jake gyllenhaal
jake actually did have girlfriend jean
cadoo with him last night just off
camera while newly single jason momoa
went solo and was presenting despite an
injury i'm a little sore oh what
happened i had hernia surgery yesterday
i said my belly button your stepdaughter
is presenting at night as well it's a
family affair you've been everywhere
supporting zoe in these last several
months i think of it like from my kids
point of view that are their dad's
aquaman or sister's
cat woman it's a trip
[Music]
zoe who posted this shot with dad lenny
kravitz got a sweet kiss inside from his
ex her big little eyes co-star nicole
kidman nicole was also sweetly hyping up
hubby keith urban's residency go see him
in vegas he was doing a gig last night
he landed at 1am so he could be here
holding my hand of course i'm pretty
convinced my name is not going to be
called jessica justine
her name wasn't just called it was
engraved in gold and jessica chastain
isn't just best actress call her best
countess the winner kissed hubby john
luca an italian count who was her
personal photographer all night but did
these two secretly tie the knot you know
that was my wife name
you're married to that seat filler jesse
plemons and kirsten dunst have been
engaged since 2017 and her rep tells et
they aren't officially married but have
referred to each other as husband and
wife for quite some time the pair left
their two kids at home we made it our
families are here they definitely have
flasks on them
more couples benedict cumberbatch smooch
wife sophie jamie dornan held hands with
his wife amelia but gave a kiss to his
photobombing former roommate andrew
garfield
courtney kardashian and travis barker
did their version of smooching on the
carpet and they weren't the only parents
serving up oscar pda
mommy
abuelita is checking out the baby
tonight
in kanto's wilmer valderrama and fiance
amanda pacheco left their one-year-old
daughter at home but family is forever
on his mind my dad knowing that i'm at
the red carpet at the oscars with a film
that speaks to him
it's just i mean i don't want to start
crying think about like the legacy
you're building for your baby i hope it
everything that i do becomes an example
of something that she can see she won't
know how difficult it was for these
moments to happen because it would be
better for her and i'm proud to be part
of that wave
the biggest thing that's going on
tonight is me bringing my daughter to
this because she's an aspiring actress
family was everywhere from presenter
diddy's date daughter chance to dane
judy dench with grandson sam who gave us
ed sheeran vibes
bradley cooper brought mom gloria we
want to thank our parents best original
song winners billy eilish and brother
phineas showed off their tight family
bond with mom maggie i never would have
in my wildest dreams really imagined it
would
you know end up the way it has oh my god
billy's win marks the third straight win
for a bond song
[Music]
earlier in the night billy delivered a
haunting performance on stage and made
good on her red carpet wish yeah i think
i'm going to just try not to suck and
like be the best that i can
it feels so good
beyonce felt alive but her stunning show
opening performance was not live e.t
confirmed the king richard power ballad
was pre-taped from the compton tennis
courts a few days earlier
in a surprise cameo ten-year-old
daughter blue ivy joined the performers
towards the end blue took a seat front
and center of queen bee's throne i mean
how do you i mean beyonce
okay
what else is there
please welcome
reba mcintyre mila kunis made it a date
night with ashton kutcher and introduced
rifa's performance of somehow you do
from mila's film for good days
[Music]
reba last took the oscar stage in 1991
that emotional performance occurred just
days after seven members of her band and
her road manager were killed in a tragic
plane crash
reba's boyfriend rex lynn was there for
support and held her hand on the carpet
making the stallion surprise cameo and
we don't talk about bruno makes her the
first female rapper to ever perform at
the oscars how does that feel to have
that title
it feels like yeah i did that now what
but the award for sweetest moment of the
night goes to lady gaga and liza minelli
presenting the best picture oscar
together you see that yeah the public
they love you gaga told eliza i got you
right before announcing koda as the big
winner troy kotzer also took home best
supporting actor for his role in the
film gaga arrived late to the awards
opting to walk the red carpet at elton
john's annual aids foundation party
where she was co-host for the evening my
husband and i are really excited about
meeting
gaga because we're obsessed
britney spears fiance sam esgari arrived
solo but gave us a wedding update what
can you tell us about wedding planning i
don't think we're going to have a bad
support tonight i know man batch of
parties are in the past so nobody's a
party but when i get the invite i'll
send you an invite as well i am
auditioning for best man we are all
super excited about this britney spears
wedding thing what can you tell us i
brought up a few pictures to show to
where she was so moved
and i find her in great spirits
fantastic
i have to congratulate you you welcomed
your 20th grandchild yes goldie at
brooklyn jenner kylie had hers just a
month ago she said her her son's name is
no longer wolf so we're all wondering
what it is what can you tell us
i cannot tell if she has not officially
announced it i have a lot of experience
on
naming people especially trying to name
yourself
that's very difficult yeah very very i
struggled with it for years meanwhile at
vanity fair kim kardashian walked the
carpet with sister kendall not pete
davidson but courtney oh she brought her
man travis
is chris pine your date tonight i mean
he's phenomenal yeah absolutely don't
leave your date
he's so beautiful
he's carrying your train i know he's the
best she carries my heart see evil
equal trade
yeah this is perfect date night
i haven't been in my wallet once
sophie turner showed off her baby bump
with hubby joe jonas at her side couples
making their red carpet debuts jon hamm
with girlfriend anna osceola and anya
taylor joy with boyfriend malcolm mcrae
but it was no date no problem for kobe's
daughter natalia bryant reggae jean
paige is back wait stop are you serious
can i look now
okay we'll see how this night goes
[Music]
oh natalia bryant is all of us that was
too cute
you